vous êtes très étriqué dans votre truc
faut penser comme vous si vous avez des
cons tout le monde pense comme moi
maintenant on va tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chanteuse Angèle qui a fait son coming
out la chanteuse belge vient de faire de
nouvelles révélations dans le magazine
Vogue l'artiste de 27 ans ont couverture
du mensuel s'est livré comme rarement
sur sa vie sentimentale et a fait cette
déclaration choc je suis en phase avec
l'idée du polyamour alors Angèle rêvait
d'avoir adopté le principe du polyamour
tout est détourné il n'a pas dit je suis
en couple exactement elle a dit qu'elle
était en phase avec l'idée exactement
quand on est artiste et qu'on a la
chance d'avoir un peu de lumière c'est
bien je trouve d'avoir des des idéaux
des de pouvoir exprimer le fait que tout
le monde a le droit d'être libre oui on
peut être un chapeau ça peut arriver
[Rires]
veut pas dire à ta femme je reviens je
vais voir la deuxième et à la deuxième
guerre je reviens
qu'on s'entend et que tout le monde que
personne ne souffre personne ne souffre
organisée en fait je pense que ça fait
subsister la libido quand même parce que
deux finir un moment ou un autre par
chercher c'est tout le temps les mêmes
caresses
c'est ça qui m'emmerde le plus
[Applaudissements]
sur la question
alors moi je suis pas du tout
un petit peu
un gros menteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un reportage et des scènes chauds qui
ont rapidement fait le buzz sur internet
mais qui ont aussi provoqué la colère
des spectateurs et de certains
chroniqueurs il faut arrêter le massacre
pour les enfants c'est irresponsable
donc le reportage qui a été tourné
effectivement il y a beaucoup de scènes
très illustratives notamment les petits
accessoires dans le coffre du
convertible qui ne sont pas un tiroir à
simplement tirer on est bien d'accord
c'est un convertible là les accessoires
ont été placés à cet endroit là
expressivement pour donner une
illustration à la situation
vous êtes choqué que les gens soient
choqués mais vous dites pas qu'on va
remettre les gens d'honneur
[Musique]
comment tu te sens toilé au bal les
laisser nous parler moi je me sens bien
après c'est sûr que ça amène à se poser
des questions que ça mène à se poser des
questions que mes parents et faire un
choix pareil et moi on en parlait avant
et moi on en parle avant et comme ils
m'ont dit c'est j'aurais mis en France
et moi j'ai des professeurs et ça je
peux le dire il savait même pas c'est
quoi le sexe donc c'est sûr ils vont pas
aller chercher eux sur internet des
vidéos de mes parents à poil d'ailleurs
mais moi ça me fait triplé de voir mes
parents sur internet donc je vais
pas le chercher
vous êtes très étriqué dans votre truc
faut penser comme vous si vous voulez
que tout le monde pense
eux ils sont ils sont heureux de faire
ce qu'ils font donc moi je suis content
pour eux après forcément je me suis dit
peut-être même faire chier à
l'école peut-être qu'on va se de
ma gueule et tout non non moi j'ai pas
vu j'ai pas constaté je peux constater
ça non les fuites en fait les
délinquants c'est pas nous nous on est
sur des plateformes quadrice sécurisant
cadrées par la loi on est soumis un
régime de l'URSSAF et on fait des impôts
les lixes donc les fuites tous les
médias sont traqués tous les jours les
plateformes et on est embauché quelqu'un
donc récemment justement pour traquer
les fuites sur le web et les plateformes
adjacent parce que avec tous mes RD il a
tout ce buzz tous bordel évidemment il y
a des petits malins ils prennent les
contenus ils les achètent ils les
repartage c'est eux les délinquants
c'est pas nous et beau de faire des
trucs sur Instagram mais reprend ta
famille en main tu dois être l'homme tu
dois être le patriarche fais attention
de pas te faire engrainer par par ta
femme qui est en train de faire
n'importe quoi
je te
nos enfants ça n'a rien à voir nos
enfants pourquoi nos enfants nos enfants
on se lève le matin on s'occupe de voilà
stop pourquoi mélanger tous les enfants
avec des contenus non là vous mélangez
tout c'est ça le truc c'est pas une
question d'argent moi mes parents s'ils
sont épanouis dans leur travail ils sont
heureux dans ce qu'ils font bah tant
mieux moi ma vie elle a pas changé et
eux ils sont heureux dans ce qu'ils font
donc je vois pas le problème alors voilà
un homme de 40 ans a été arrêté par la
police de Strasbourg pour avoir jeté son
chien par la fenêtre de son appartement
l'homme passait hier devant le tribunal
correctionnel de Strasbourg pour être
juger il a été condamné à une peine de
12 mois de prison dont 8 mois ferme bon
concrètement on a un homme qui était bon
alcoolisé et qui aurait jeté son chien
donc un petit bouledogue par la fenêtre
du cinquième étage donc c'était lundi le
chien atterri 15 mètres plus bas il est
pas malheureux malheureusement mort sur
le coup donc il a agonisé pendant un
certain temps quand même il avait de
multiples fractures des hémorragés
internes etc donc il va prendre 8 mois
de prison il va passer huit alors je
suis pas sûr qu'il reste 8 mois aussi je
pense qu'il va faire trois quatre mois
exactement
il aura été en prison c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit oui vous c'est bien alors il
risque 50 on est bien d'accord mais pour
une fois qu'il y a une condamnation
ferme avec mandat de dépôt moi je trouve
que on va dans le bon sens c'est que
dalle il va faire 3 mois de prison ferme
pour acte de cruauté il a pris son chien
il a jeté par le balcon evidemment que
c'est pas assez c'est peut-être le début
de quelque chose parce que faire de la
prison mais on va pas se réjouir qu'en
France pour une fois enfin il y a un
petit début de quelque chose dans les
lois tu peux pas te réjouir de ça
quelque part je suis même d'accord avec
Gilles parce que généralement quand il y
a des sévices sur animaux on voit très
souvent que en fait il y a même pas de
peine au final donc c'est déjà bien mais
bien sûr que ce n'est pas assez mais il
faut que les lois changent vraiment
grave c'est aussi cas quasiment aussi
grave qu'un homicide c'est très très
grave de faire ça et à quel moment on se
dit pardon mais ah ok non mais c'est
c'est à quel moment on se dit c'est OK
parce que j'étais bourré j'ai bu un peu
pardon mais c'est pas une excuse d'être
bourré c'est une circonstance aggravante
je trouve que comme l'a dit Gilles ça va
servir de jurisprudence c'est la
première fois malgré tout que quelqu'un
est condamné par rapport à un animal par
exemple quand on a vu kurtzouma le
footballeur qui avait un peu massacré
son chat bon bah à la fin on se sentir
par quoi par un stage de citoyenneté à
la membrane qui sert à rien et qui est
en Angleterre donc c'est quand même bien
malgré tout que nous en France malgré
tout on marque le voilà après
malheureusement oui nos prisons sont
pleines à craquer il aurait fallu quoi
il aurait fallu mettre 5 ans ça t'aurait
convenu 5 ans 10 ans c'est quoi en fait
c'est quand même c'est quand même pas
mal moi je trouve pour Guillaume pour
Guillaume c'est aussi grave que tu es
humain
pour vous c'est pas plus grave
est-ce que c'est plus grave de tuer pour
vous quand Guillaume dit c'est plus
c'est aussi grave que de tuer un un
humain quand vous êtes d'accord
moi par exemple si quelqu'un si
quelqu'un tu me retiens je serai dévasté
mais si quelqu'un tu mon fils je suis
morte voilà vous voyez les échelles
mais c'est parce qu'on dit qu'on dit
c'est que si effectivement on doit
sauver un animal ou un animal ou un être
vivant effectivement on va on va sauver
d'abord l'être vivant mais en revanche
tu es un espace petit Guillaume mais
Guillaume il dit que c'est aussi grave
de tuer un chien que c'est ça est-ce que
la souffrance c'est la même pourquoi qui
on est pour dire que la souffrance d'un
chien d'un chat elle est inférieur et ce
qui m'énerve c'est que les gens en fait
ils sont contents de prendre des chiens
ont des chats quand c'est pour faire
deux Story sur Instagram après quand il
faut assumer derrière c'est pas comme ça
c'est un cadeau mais non désolé
pour toi
je suis venu pour toi je t'ai dit deux
mots dans le couloir tu te souviens
ouais d'accord maintenant non non non
tu ne peux pas
être très sérieux tu passes à TF1 tu vas
connaître gloire et beauté tu vois ici
on connaît gloire et beauté
c'était parfait et après qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans ta tête après quand tu
quittes TF1 qu'est-ce qui se passe à ce
moment-là je vois quelqu'un un homme et
une femme peu importe qui
le père qui bat sa femme c'est un trauma
il y en a plein des traumas d'accord
bien sûr d'accord maintenant là il y a
une petite différence c'est qu'on est
avec une histoire de sexe tu veux pas
dire non maintenant le sexe c'est quoi
c'est visuel c'est les images qui vont
rester c'est pas les paroles pas
beaucoup d'accord dans la tête de
l'enfant
mémorise d'accord après il rencontre une
femme
il y a l'image de sa femme et après il y
a cette image qui vient se superposer et
il sait plus avec qui baise est-ce que
tu comprends le problème oui je crois
que là elle a compris
quand on est jeune quand on a la vie
devant soi qu'on peut faire des erreurs
et c'est vrai que vous arrivez à un
stade à un âge où vous avez plein
d'enfants vous êtes passé sur TF1 vous
avez construit quelque chose et c'est
vrai que c'est assez rare de faire ses
choix vos âges
donc la seule question c'est pourquoi et
pourquoi parce qu'en fait c'est quelque
chose qui nous épanouit déjà depuis
longtemps
je vais vous répondre
je peux faire plein de choses pour
l'argent et pas forcément être
exactement
et peut-être le besoin de notoriété
en fait c'est un choix tout simplement
et là il faut l'entendre alors c'est
vrai que les esprits étriqués et très
une stérilisé j'ai envie de dire ne pas
l'entendre parce que c'est un choix qui
nous épanouit vos jeunes iront sur
Internet et verront c'est ça
[Musique]
pour Hervé chevreau le maire de la ville
qui a décidé tout simplement d'annuler
la célébration du mariage c'est pas la
première fois très bien vous êtes le
frère et le cousin du marié qui est le
frère et moi d'accord et vous êtes le
cousin c'est parti d'une embrouille on
va dire en train de l'automobiliste en
entrant entre excusez-moi un
automobiliste et un autre automobiliste
d'accord l'individu qui n'était pas
content à essayer de shooter un des gens
du cortège c'est ce qui s'est passé
celui qui en moto et en fait on essaie
de le shooter de le shooter sa jambe
c'est parti de là en fait et là donc les
deux personnes se sont donc un peu
embrouillées il y a eu un coup qui est
parti la personne est remontée dans sa
voiture on lui a demandé de s'en aller
donc on l'a dit va-t'en c'est bon repas
à ce moment-là qu'est-ce qu'il a fait en
fait avec sa voiture il a enclenché une
première et il a tapé volontairement un
véhicule du cortège alors moi
malheureusement je la version de la
victime parce que je pense qu'il faut
pas le monsieur a raison on n'a pas tout
filmé il parle pas des mortiers qui ont
été lancés sur la voie publique pendant
le le déroulement du cortège et là du
coup c'est pas la même version que
Monsieur il est sorti du véhicule il a
frappé à la fenêtre du du monsieur il
lui a dit sors je vais te casser la
gueule déjà c'est pas du tout la même
version et le gars insisté et le gars
sans faire exprès la victime a relâché
le frein et à percuter le véhicule vous
verrez quand vous aurez des enfants si
vous êtes avec votre enfant de 5 ans à
l'arrière et qui a un gars qui vient qui
pète votre fenêtre avec des gènes
mortiers je sais pas peut-être qu'il
devait aller chez le médecin avec sa
fille mais c'est normal on a le droit de
couper la route d'ailleurs pour vous
c'est normal mais normalement il reste
il existe des règles d'accord on peut
pas interdire nous les pollutions on a
le droit mais on n'a pas le droit
d'empêcher les gens d'aller venir ça
veut dire que vous êtes responsable
quand même même le gars aurait tort vous
êtes responsable vous êtes un effet de
masse vous passez au mieux des gens vous
dérangez les gens avec le cortège comme
ça j'étais fait une première fois
parfois en tirant sur du brûlure
klaxonnant vous avez un cortège vous
êtes responsable vous êtes un groupe un
groupe de une masse et ça veut dire que
vous savez très bien que si jamais ça
dérape il va y avoir cette espèce de
phénomène de masse ce qui s'est passé là
donc c'était à vous de tenir ce cortège
et quand bien même le gars vous agresse
et quand même le gars le premier à vous
à vous à vous insulter vous calmer les
choses c'était à vous de gérer ça vous
n'avez pas géré aujourd'hui vos amis ne
sont pas mariés et pourquoi à cause de
vous et uniquement à cause de ce cortège
qui a dérapé parce que vous n'avez pas
subtenir et là vous êtes en train de
nous expliquer qu'en fait c'est de sa
faute il fallait pas qu'il rentre dans
sa rue j'ai pas dit ça voilà juste à un
moment vous voyez c'est ça le problème
et nous en tout cas en tant que
pollution on aimerait avoir on aurait pu
arriver plus vite on aurait peut-être pu
éviter ça mais aujourd'hui dans le 93
c'est un des le département le plus
criminogène de France on peut plus faire
face à ça parce que vous imaginez chaque
si on devait suivre chaque cortège de
sortir un quartier comme vous dites ou
comme vous le pensez vous certaines
cultures là je suis pas d'accord mais tu
parlais qu'en tant que policier mais
voilà en fait nous on n'a pas les moyens
en tant que policier on n'a pas assez
d'effectif pour pour arriver à combattre
ça juste c'est la voie publique et même
si ce que tu m'as dit pendant la pub et
je te crois tu m'as dit c'est lui qui
nous a insulté le premier peu importe
vous êtes un cortège voilà vous êtes un
cortège de mariée vous étiez là vous
étiez nombreux et tu insultes tu passes
à autre chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]